>>> THE KREMLIN NOW WARNING FOR
UKRAINE TO PAY IF GERMANY AND
OTHERS PLOY TANKS TO HELP IN THE
WAR EFFORT.
FRED PLEITGEN JOINS US.
WHAT ARE YOU HEARING?
>> Reporter: YEAH.
THIS THREAT MADE BY THE KREMLIN
EARLIER TODAY.
THE SPOKESMAN FOR THE KREMLIN
SAYING IF THE WESTERN-MADE
BATTLE TANKS NO MATTER WHEN WE
COME FROM ESPECIALLY THOSE MADE
IN GERMANY, SAYING THEY WOULD
PAY.
MASSIVE RETALIATION ON THEIR
PART.
SOMETHING WE'VE HEARD FROM
RUSSIANS IN THE PAST.
IF YOU RECALL, WHEN THE U.S. END
ROCKET LAUNCHING SYSTEMS TO
UKRAINE RUSSIANS THREATENED TO
HIT DECISION-MAKING CENTERS IN
KYIV AND OTHER CITIES AS WELL.
SO FAR THAT REALLY HASN'T
HAPPENED TO THE EXTENT RUSSIA
SAID THAT IT WOULD.
NEVERTHELESS, THE MAIN BATTLE
TANKS ARE A HUGE TOPIC HERE IN
KYIV.
HEARING FROM UKRAINIAN OFFICIAL.
THEY'RE RUNNING OUT OF SPARE
PARTS FOR THE SOVIET-MADE BATTLE
TANKS THEY HAVE.
ALSO RUNNING OUT OF AMMO.
VERY DIFFICULT TO SOURCE THAT
INTERNATIONALLY ALSO.
UKRAINIANS SAY THEY NEED ABOUT
300 TO 400 MODERN WESTERN BATTLE
TANKS TO REALLY BE ABLE TO TURN
THE TIDE.
AS YOU CORRECTLY SAID, RIGHT NOW
IT'S STILL DIFFICULT
INTERNATIONALLY.
ESPECIALLY FOR THE GERMAN-MADE
ONES, THE GERMAN 2s.
POLS SAYING THEY WANT THEM SEND,
OWN THEM, BUT NEEDMISSION FROM
GERMANS.
THE GERMANS SAYING THEY WILL IF
THE U.S. SEND ABRAMS TANKS.
THE U.S. THINKS THEY'RE NOT
SUITED FOR THE BATTLEFIELD HERE
IN UKRAINE MAKING THIS ALSO
DIFFICULT.
GERMANS SAY IT'S BEING WORKED
OUT AT THE MOMENT, NOT THERE
YET.
A LOT OF COUNTRIES SEE THE
NECESSITIES OF HE'S WESTERN
BATTLE TANKS TO GET TO UKRAINE.
>> DIDN'T BEFORE.
DEFINITELY A CHANGE IN TONE THEY
SEE IT NOW.
THANK YOU FOR BEING THERE.
>>> JOINING ME FOR MORE ON THIS
A DEMOCRATIC CONGRESSWOMAN FROM
PENNSYLVANIA WHO SITS ON THE
FOREIGN AFFAIRS COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
WHEN YOU HEAR THE RUSSIAN
GOVERNMENT SAY UKRAINE WILL PAY
IF ANYONE SENDS THEM TANKS WHAT
DO YOU MAKE OF THAT THREAT?
>> I SAY WHAT THE PERSON
PREVIOUS TO ME SAID.
FEELS AS THOUGH WE'VE HEARD THIS
THREAT BEFORE AND, FRANKLY, THE
ACTIONS OF THE RUSSIANS ARE
INEXPLICABLY -- AGGRESSIVE.
AND I THINK SHOW TOTALLY EXPECT
WE WOULD ANSWER WITH THESE KINDS
OF WEAPON SYSTEMS.
I HAVE ACTUALLY BEEN NOT ONLY ON
THE ARMS SERVICES COMMITTEE BUT
ALSO ON THE FOREIGN AFFAIRS
COMMITTEE ADVOCATING FOR US AS
AMERICANS, AS THE UNITED STATES,
MAKING SURE WE ARE EQUIPPING THE
UKRAINIANS WITH EVERYTHING
THEY'RE ASKING FOR INCLUDING AT
THIS POINT TANKS.
I DON'T THINK SABRE RATTLING
FROM RUSSIA SHOULD BE SOMETHING
THAT SHOULD STOP US OR OUR
ALLIES FROM BEING IN SUPPORT OF
UKRAINE AS THEY FIGHT FOR
DEMOCRACIES AROUND THE WORLD.
>> AND IF IT IS SABRE RATTLES,
AS SAID, HEARD THE THREAT
BEFORE.
NOT LIKE IT STOPPED RUSSIA FROM
BEING RUTHLESS.
AT ITS CORE, THEN WHAT DO YOU
THINK IS DRIVING HESITANCY FROM
GERMANY?
THE HESITANCY -- WHAT DO YOU
THINK IS DRIVING THE HESITANCY
FROM THE U.S. TO SEND TANKS?
>> IT REALLY SOUNDS AS THOUGH
THERE IS SOME WORK TO BE DONE IN
TERMS OF CONVERSATIONS BETWEEN
ALLIES BOTH THE UNITED STATES
AND GERMANY AND HEARTENED BY THE
CONVERSATION COMING OUT OF THE
ARMED SERVICES COMMITTEE FROM
CHAIRMAN McCAUL WHO RECENTLY
SAID WE NEED TO MAKE SURE E ARE
ANSWERING THE CALL FOR UKRAINE
FOR EVERYTHING THAT THEY NEED,
AND THAT THERE IS A PROCESS THAT
NEEDS TO HAPPEN HERE
DOMESTICALLY TO EDUCATE OUR
CONGRESS AND ADMINISTRATION AND
OUR D.O.D. TO MAKE IT POSSIBLE
TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT.
THEN I BELIEVE GERMANY WILL
FOLLOW ALONG, FOLLOW SUIT.
THAT'S BEEN SORT OF THE PATTERN
SINCE BEGINNING OF THE WAR.
A FEW HUNDRED DAYS AGO.
>> I WANT TO PLAY FOR YOU KIND
OF RIGHT ALONG THE LINES WHAT
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT.
PLAY HOW THE REPUBLICAN CHAIRMAN
OF FOREIGN AFFAIRS RESPONDED TO
CONCERNS THE NEW REPUBLICAN
MAJORITY MIGHT NOT BE AS
SUPPORTIVE SENDING AID TO
UKRAINE IN THE FUTURE.
LET ME PLAY THIS.
>> WE HAVE TO EDUCATE THEM.
YOP THINK THEY QUITE UNDERSTAND
WHAT IS AT STAKE.
IF UKRAINE FAULLS, CHAIRMAN XI
WILL INVADE TAIWAN.
PUTTING DRONES IN KOREA AND
NORTH KOREA PUTTING AR PTILLERY
INTO RUSSIA, THSHE TO UNDERSTAND
THE CASE.
>> DO YOU SEE THAT AS WELL?
WHAT IS IT GOING TO TAKE TO
CONVINCE THE SKEPTICS?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
I HOPE NOW REPUBLICANS HAVE
MAJORITY IN THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES, I HOPE NOW THAT
CHAIRMAN McCAUL IS CHAIRMAN
THOSE FOLKS ON THE OTHER SIDE OF
THE AISLE, REPUBLICANS ON OTHER
SIDE OF THE AISLE WILL START
REALLY LISTENING TO THE CHAIRMAN
AS WE ARTICULATES IVY VERY, VERY
WELL WHAT'S AT STAKE HERE.
THIS IS NOT JUST ABOUT UKRAINE.
THIS IS, IN FACT, THE WORLD
WATCHING WHAT HAPPENS FOR
UKRAINE, TO UKRAINE SO WE CAN
MAKE SURE WE PROTECT AS I
MENTIONED DEMOCRACIES AROUND THE
WORLD.
THE IMPLICATIONS ARE A FAILURE
IN UKRAINE ARE GLOBAL.
I AM VERY GRATEFUL, VERY PLEASED
I SIT ON ARMED SERVICES AND
FOREIGN AFFAIRS, RESOLUTE IN
THEIR UNITY WITH DEMOCRATS AND
REPUBLICANS ALIKE.
RECENTLY ANOTHER TRIP TO UKRAINE
THE CONGRESSIONAL DELEGATION
FROM UKRAINE JUST HAD BACK.
I HAD OPPORTUNITY TO GO MYSELF
AND SPEAK WITH PRESIDENT
ZELENSKYY EARLY ON.
NOTHING CHANGED OTHER THAN WE
NEED TO CONTINUE TO SUPPORT
UKRAINE.
>> IT IS ALSO IMPORTANT TO POINT
OUT WHEN THERE IS THE BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AROUND THEE ISSUES.
WE SEE THAT ON THE WORK YOU'RE
DOING ON THE COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU.
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME.
LET'S GET SOME PERSPECTIVE FROM
MARK HERTLING.
>> GREAT TO BE WITH YOU, JIM.
>> THERE IS NO ALTERNATIVE TO
BATTLE TANKS LIKE THIS BUT THERE
IS A SCHOOL OF THOUGHT INCLUDING
ON THE U.S. SIDE THAT TANKS ARE
NOT WHAT UKRAINE NEEDS RIGHT
NOW.
AND THAT THEIR WHOLE HOST OF
CHALLENGES STANDING IN THE WAY
OF THEM BEING A TRUE
GAME-CHANGER ON THE GROUND.
SO WHAT IS YOUR VIEW?
>> JIM, I THINK WE HAVE TO GO
BACK TO WHAT THE GOAL HAS BEEN
FROM VARIOUS ALLIES AND WHICH
HAS BEEN LED BY SECRETARY
AUSTIN.
THE GOAL TO PROVIDE UKRAINE WITH
THE ABILITY THEY COULD
IMMEDIATELY USE AND EASILY
SUSTAIN.
ALL THREE OF THOSE FACTORS ARE
REALLY DYNAMIC IN TERMS OF
DECISION-MAKING ON WHAT
EQUIPMENT THAT THEY NEED.
NOW WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT TANKS,
THAT REQUIRES SOVEREIGN
DECISIONS ON THE PART OF THE
WESTERN ALLIANCE LIKE WE'RE
SEEING WITH GERMANY RIGHT NOW.
BUT THERE IS SAY LOT OF
COMPLEXITY BEHIND
DECISION-MAKING PROCESS.
THE AVAILABILITY OF THE AMMO AND
THE PARTS AND FUEL AND TRAINING
REQUIREMENTS AND THE ABILITY OF
THE GAMING UNIT TO SUSTAIN THE
VEHICLES ON A HIGHLY MOBILE AND
HIGH OP TEMPO AND DYNAMIC
BATTLEFIELD INTERCONNECTEDNESS
WITH OTHER ALLIES AND THE MILT
GOALS OF THE OPERATION.
WE COULD DISCUSS THOSE AD
NAUSEAM.
BUT FACT OF THE MATTER IS, TO
ANSWER YOUR QUESTION, YES, IT
WOULD BE GREAT TO GIVE UKRAINE
TANKS AND HAVE THEM FALL INTO
BATTLE POSITIONS WITHOUT A NEED
TO TRAIN OR SUSTAIN THE
UKRAINIAN ARMY, BUT THAT IS NOT
GOING TO HAPPEN REALLY SOON.
OTHER NATIONS DONATED A WHOLE
LOT OF COMBAT VEHICLES THAT I
THINK WILL CONTRIBUTE
SIGNIFICANTLY TO THE KIND OF
OPERATIONS UKRAINE IS GOING TO
BE CONDUCTING IN THE VERY NEAR
FUTURE.
>> THAT IS POINT I'VE HEARD.
THEY'VE HAD SUCCESS WITH SMALL
UNIT FORCES HIGHLY NIMBLE,
RIGHT, IN TERMS ATTACKING
RUSSIAN ARMOR WHICH IS FRANKLY
MAR FOR NUMEROUS THERE.
IS THERE SOMETHING ELSE, THEN,
THAT YOU BELIEVE UKRAINE NEEDS
MORE OF AND QUICKLY.
I KNOW THERE HAS BEEN A CONSTANT
FRUSTRATION FROM THE UKRAINIAN
SIDE, THANK YOU FOR ALL YOU'RE
GIVING US, BUT WEE  NEED IT MOR
AND FASTER.
>> WHEN THE ANNOUNCEMENT WAS
MADE FOR THE BRADLEYS AN THE
STRYKERS, I THOUGHT THAT WAS A
GOOD VEHICLE.
THEY WANT TO MOVE FAST WITHOUT A
LONG AND DYNAMIC SUPPLY LINE.
AND THEY WANT TO HAVE A LOT OF
TANK KILLING CAPABILITY.
BOTH OF THOSE VEHICLES, IF YOU
PUT A TEN SOLDIERS IN THE BACK
OF A STRYKER WITH A JAVELIN, YOU
COULD REALLY GET BEHIND ENEMY
LINES VERY QUICKLY AND GET
THROUGH THE FRONT.
IT IS AN INFANTRY BUS.
IT DOESN'T HAVE A LOT OF WEAPONS
ON THE VEHICLE ITSELF.
BUT WHAT IS IN THE BACK OF THE
VEHICLE IS CRITICALLY IMPORTANT.
SAME THING TOR THE BRADLEY.
THEY HAVE TOE KILLERS AND A LOT
OF INFANTRY MEN AT THAT.
>> THAT IS RIGHT.
YOU MENGED THE JAVELIN.
AND TH
AND THE TANK KILLER.
YOU COULD GIVE US A SENSE OF
WHERE THIS WAR STANDS?
IT HAS BEEN A BRUTAL BATTLE.
I LOT OF FOLKS AT HOME DON'T
KNOW THE LEVEL OF CASUALTIES
THAT ARE HAPPENING ON A DAILY
BASIS ON THIS EASTERN FRONT.
YOU HEARD OF DEATH TOLLS
AMOUNTING IN THE DOZENS EVERY
SINGLE DAY.
HAVE WE REACHED SOMETHING OF
AWAR OF ATTRITION THERE IN THE
EAST?
>> IT HAS BEEN A WAR OF
ATTRITION SINCE ABOUT APRIL,
JIM.
BUT THE ATTRITION TRUTHFULLY AND
I WATCHED THIS BATTLE EVERY DAY,
VERY CLOSELY.
WHAT YOU'RE SEEING IS NOT DOZENS
OF CASUALTIES ON THE FRONT
LINES, YOU'RE SEEING HUNDREDS.
GEM MILLEY SAID THE OTHER DAY
THAT RUSSIA HAS SUSTAINED CLOSE
TO 100,000 CASUALTIES.
THAT IS UNFATHOMABLE AND THAT IS
LOWER THAN WHAT UKRAINE IS
SUGGESTING THEY'VE SUFFERED.
THEY'RE PUTTING THE NUMBERS UP
TO ABOUT 120,000 IN 11 MONTHS OF
WAR.
OF COURSE, UKRAINE, WE DON'T
KNOW HOW MANY CASUALTIES THEY'VE
SUFFERED.
BUT I WOULD SUGGEST IT IS AN
AWFUL LOT.
THIS IS A WORLD WAR 2
BATTLEFIELD AND IT IS JUST
UNBELIEVABLY DRAMATIC AND
CHALLENGING AND WHAT WE'RE
SEEING RIGHT NOW IS NOT A
STALEMATE, THERE ARE A LOT OF
BATTLES GOING ON AS YOU'VE
REPORTED MULTIPLE TIMES IN THE
EAST AND THE SOUTHEAST.
RUSSIA IS TRYING TO GET MORE
MOBILIZED SOLDIERS,
UNFORTUNATELY THOSE SOLDIERS ARE
NOT TRAINED.
SO THEY'RE MORE CANNON FODDER OR
MEAT AS THEY SAY IN RUSSIA.
TO THE FRONT LINE.
AND UKRAINE IS TRYING TO GET
MOVING AND CONDUCT OPERATIONS
THAT ARE OFFENSIVE IN NATURE.
>> YEAH, THAT PHRASE CANNON MEAT
HAS STRUCK ME AS A DEMONSTRATION
OF THE LACK OF PROTECTION,
RESPECT THAT RUSSIA OFTEN HAS
FOR ITS FRONT LINE FORCES.
MART HERTLING, GOOD TO HAVE YOU
ON.
>> IT IS GREAT TO BE WITH YOU,
JIM, THANKS.